[Music]
we concluded the previous video by
understanding the first law of chemical
combination now we need to take a look
at the second law which is called the
law of constant proportions of the law
of definite proportions they're the same
thing the law was first put forth in the
year 1797 by a French chemist called
Joseph Proust and hence is also referred
to as the Proust's law what does the law
state the law states that in a chemical
substance elements are always in a fixed
proportion by mass now what does this
mean it's not straightforward to
comprehend the statement at the first
glance remember the example of chocolate
milk that we considered while studying
the first law in that example we saw
that when we have to make double or
triple the amount of chocolate milk all
we have to do is use the proportionate
amount of the individual ingredients
wait did I say proportionate amount what
does that mean it means that when we
have to make the drink for ten people
instead of five we just have to take
double the amount of ingredients right
anything more or less would result in
change of taste
similarly in any chemical substance the
elements present are always in a fixed
proportion by mass so let us take the
example of elements a and B giving us
the compound see now the FIH observe
just one single unit of the compound c
then we can notice that it has two atoms
of element a and three atoms of element
b is it true for all the units making up
the compound c yes it means that even if
one atom from any of these units is
removed or added that it can no longer
be called compound c it will change to
something different so if the number of
atoms is fixed then the mass will also
be constant right absolutely the best
example to study this is that of ammonia
if we decompose ammonia by any means say
by extreme heat or some other way then
we get the nitrogen and hydrogen atoms
in the same proportions by mass
so let's say we take 17 grams of ammonia
if we decomposed it then we will get 14
grams of nitrogen and 3 grams of
hydrogen so can we say nitrogen and
hydrogen are present in ammonia in a
constant ratio of 14 to 3 even if we
decompose ammonia in any other way the
ratio of nitrogen to hydrogen in the
compound will always be the same 14 to 3
yes and this is seen in all the
compounds existing naturally or even
artificially but when these laws were
put forth in the form of theories
proving them was quite a concern all
these explanations that we know now are
due to experiments performed for many
decades several scientists came up with
many experiments and explanations among
all a notable theory by the name
Dalton's atomic theory surfaced as an
answer to many of these questions the
theory was put forth by the English
chemist and physicist John Dalton watch
the next video to understand what Dalton
had to say about this theory
you